hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I'm really
sorry for the stream starting late I
started up my computer and I was I
couldn't connect to the internet it said
there are no networks which I was
connected on all my other devices so
that was weird and then once I did get
connected I realized that like I was
logged out of everything and had to use
like my two-factor authentication to get
back in so sorry about that
but now we're up and running and it's
been a while so hey everyone sorry it's
been so long
things have been a little bit wild for
me lately
I've been speaking at some conferences
and all the talks that I've done are
available so I guess if you want let me
know I could give you some links to
those also I bought a new house and
moved in my new house and you already
knew that because I did get moved in
before I did my last stream but I've
been getting the old house ready to sell
so I've been spending time over there
cleaning and fixing and moving stuff so
things have been wild also just want to
mention this briefly since I know this
there's some of you that are also
dealing with this my depression got a
little bit rough lately and when I get
real depressed then it's hard to do
anything let alone live stream so want
to be totally honest and say that was
also part of the reason why I haven't
been streaming lately just super hard to
get up in the morning when you're like
that you know but I think I'm getting
I'm getting better now so so enough
about me let's get let's get to this so
we have a new project I'm really excited
about this so let me tell well I got a
lot of a lot of chats
let me check let me say hello to
everybody in the chain
right now and just let you know that I
will get to the chat and read all your
comments and and try to answer all your
questions I'm gonna take a little break
a little later on and do that so if
you're talking to me in the chat I'm not
ignoring you at least not for that long
and I will get to it so just hang in
there okay so here's the backstory
behind this project because it was a
little unexpected but I think it's going
to be really awesome and helpful to the
whole free code camp community so I was
at NDC Minnesota so it's a Norwegian
Developers Conference in Minnesota and I
was lucky enough to be able to speak
there and I gave a talk about react
native and using react native web like
we were doing with with this last
project that's gonna be just on pause
slightly so we're not I'm not abandoning
that project I'm just pausing it to work
on something which I think is more
important right now
so after the talk
Glenn Faraday who's a big contributor to
free code camp she came up to me and was
was talking to me about react native web
and she's been working on a react native
curriculum for free code camp so if
you're not if you haven't checked that
out yet
on free code camp org there's a ton of
lessons on all different types of coding
it's it's primarily JavaScript based but
you know you can learn a lot of stuff on
there so anyway we already have a
curriculum you know about react and
redux but we don't have react native yet
so she's already built out this amazing
curriculum on react native but there's
one problem you can't easily run react
native in the browser editor so if you
haven't seen it before let me just show
you how this works I was gonna explain
it to you but now it seems like I could
just show you and it wouldn't be so much
better so see if it'll let me sign in
quickly there we go alright so we'll go
to the curriculum this is available to
everybody right so I want to see one
that already has stuff written in it to
see how it works so let me go go back
here and I'll just go to one that's
really easy I think the cat app is here
all right this one's super easy to
understand hello world goes here so you
write your code here you could write you
know whatever you want let's put an h2
in here right so this part is your code
editor in the middle and then over here
it automatically shows what you're
writing right now HTML is easy because
this is a browser and browsers around
HTML and even regular react is easy
because it's just a JavaScript framework
it rip runs in in the browser but react
native is different this react native is
designed to run primarily on mobile
devices right so you can't just do this
and have it work over here so that was
that was the issue so Gwen and I tried
to work on that at the conference and
see like could we get this to work and
there didn't seem to be an easy way to
do it so I said well why don't I try to
do this as part of my live stream
because I think this would be kind of a
cool a cool thing to work on because I
think some of what we're doing in the
last project will be helpful here namely
react native web it's a react native web
takes react native code and changes it
into code that the browser
can read and that's exactly what we need
here okay but there's one issue that
that and that's the one we need to fix
right is that with react native web
sorry
just notice my camera was like cutting
off my head but with react native web
like we're running that on our local
machine right we have a web pack going
and all that so there's things that we
have locally that we don't really have
in the browser so that's the technical
challenge that we need to get around all
right so hopefully that wasn't too long
of an intro and if it's still confusing
I think it'll be less confusing once we
get into it so fortunately someone else
has already done a lot of the work for
this there's an open source project out
there that we can start with and try to
figure out how we can adapt it to work
with free code camp so that's the place
that I think we should start so I'm
gonna go react native play okay so there
is a project on github let's view the
license real quick just to make sure
BSD Sanibel copyright notice
I
so what we're gonna do so I was just
checking out out the license I didn't
explain that I wanted to make sure the
license was not restricting us in terms
of like not being able to use this so
this is BSD license redistribution uses
source and binary forms with or without
modification are permitted provided the
following conditions are met so we got
to keep the copyright notice and
documentation alright so we can't use
Facebook or its contributors to endorse
or promote this which is actually kind
of odd that it has Facebook in it but
anyway that's that's the license so we
should be good we just got to make sure
we provide attribution right so let me
show you what this project does let me
make this bigger all right so on the
Left we have react native so we're
bringing in all these from react native
we're importing some components we're
using those react native components
which normally would not work you know
by default on the web but over here we
can see that it's it's showing up and
it's changing see I'm like on the fly is
changing I just deleted some characters
and it changes this is exactly what we
want the only issue is the way we
implement this is it's basically like a
whole package right so it wouldn't fit
in with the free code camp UI right the
way it's set up now but we want it to
fit in like that so my there's two
options given here we can import that
web player
like if we're using react adjust to the
import otherwise we can do an iframe so
I have two approaches here to make this
work
the first one is maybe we can try to
import this and work it into the UI and
see it if that works like see if we can
override styles and things like that
enough to make this work I'd say that's
probably the faster way the easier way
to do it the other way which we may have
to do is look at how this is happening
right and kind of pull out the core
functionality from this from this repo
and put it into free code camp
so those are my approaches if anybody
has any other ideas that I'm missing
here let me know but for now I think we
get we at least have a plan I do want to
let you know like how this basically
like this the key to this working is
basically like a web worker and let me
see where it said
that's sorry I don't know why I opened
the dist
so I'm not gonna go through here I I
don't know which file is it the babble
worker yeah this is it I was right in
front of me the whole time okay so a web
worker is like a it's a file in it's a
JavaScript father runs in your browser
but it's almost like a separate I don't
know if this is exactly the right turn
but turn but it's almost like a separate
thread right that you can run things and
so like you send stuff to this file it
can do computations and send it back to
the browser so I believe that this type
of thing right being able to transform
things on the fly this is the key to how
this is working right so if we need to
pull functionality out it's gonna be
some of this stuff but like I said
hopefully we can get it to work the
other way around so now let's check out
the actual free code camp repo actually
let's check out
let's check this out so so Gwen Faraday
has her own Fork a frico camp where
she's been working on this and that's
where we're gonna work from because
that's where she has all her her updated
stuff so let me make sure I'm there I'm
on the right branch so let me once I get
it to the right place I'll copy and
paste the link so you all can can check
it out as well and I'll check let me
copy and paste the react native web
player link for you too I'm gonna have
to update the description to this video
with all the links later on so hopefully
I don't forget to do that for everyone
watching later okay there is a react
native branch here so react native
challenges there's two of them
yeah we got native challenges okay so I
think the react natives challenge this
branch is where we want to go go off of
and so let's see here is the full link
I'm gonna give about maybe like four
more minutes and then I'm going to take
a break and answer some questions in the
chat okay
so let's find our curriculum and
challenges with English and these are
the react native challenges or I'm sorry
this see these are all the challenges
and we're gonna find the react native
ones okay so this is a separate at least
right now it's organized like as this
whole separate sections it's section ten
and let's find one all right let's find
this class component one let's see if
this would be a good one to try okay
oh yeah this one seems like it's I want
to I want to do a simple challenge so
that like basically we don't run the
risk of messing things up because we
mess up the challenge right I want it to
be as simple as possible so this is just
rendering a basic component I had a
basic class component all right and we
can we'll definitely need to run this
project so I'm gonna open this up sit in
another tab so we don't lose this one
and hopefully good directions here when
you go to work on like a repo you've
never worked on before you should always
check out the documentation first like
the readme and there's usually some sort
of instructions on how to get started
did I miss the contributing there we go
here's the contributing so
we're gonna have to we're gonna make a
fork of this right we'll create a new
branch yeah so this is gonna be a little
bit weird cuz we're we're trading the
fourth of a fork essentially so like
then we're gonna submit the pull request
to gwen and then if it works for her
then it would be incorporated into her
stuff and then she could submit the pull
request the free code camp so this is
like one extra step from normally doing
it but that's that's how we have to do
it for now
okay so name the branch all this is is
pretty basic etiquette for for pull
requests this is what I really wanted to
see was I'm human so okay so we're using
gulp and power alright okay and we're
gonna have to do the the database okay
there's gonna be some cool setup that
we'll have to go through here alright
but that's fine all right step one let's
create a fork Oh
so we can let's leave this open a
contributor guide let's create the fort
here make sure we're in stage a
it's for the AR t-43 code camp all right
then I wanna fork I don't think I forked
it from Glenn's de-ice this this might
be a good I don't know if you can fork
based on the branch or if I could pull
down a branch how about I delete mine
let's do that whoops
I fork this a long time ago I don't even
want to mess with updating it so I'm
just gonna delete it
alright danger deletes all right
that's for this whoops
I'm still on Jessie why go for yukata
can't but I won't afford that there we
go alright there we go alright so while
that's working now it was a great time
for me to stop well I guess that I guess
that was really fast but I do want to go
back to the chats I said I would stop
and go back to the chat so I'm gonna
stop now answer some questions in the
chat and then we'll get back to this
next step is actually pulling this down
and getting it running and yeah I did I
did want to verify that we have that
seat is this one this is forth from
Gwen's and not directly from free code
camp so we have all of Gwen's stuff okay
all right there's a lot of people saying
hello so hey everybody good to see you
this morning I'm gonna skip through a
lot of the hellos though because there's
there's so many of them just gonna give
one big hello to everyone
Ozzie says good luck with your
depression thank you I appreciate that
yeah actually him possibly got into a
study like a depression study on using
new treatment techniques so I'm really
excited about that it's with the
University of Pittsburgh and the
hospital system here's UPMC so it's
about like using neurofeedback from like
an MRI to help like train your brain so
that's really cool hopefully that that
goes well but July assess asking what
language we use JavaScript we use in
JavaScript Kevin says if you want to
develop a web ecommerce project what do
you recommend what language for the web
e-commerce projects if if you want to do
it from scratch then probably should
write it and I would recommend full
stack JavaScript because then you only
have to learn one language but if I if
you don't ecommerce I recommend maybe
trying to take a look at some of the
already developed solutions to that so
in like WordPress land WooCommerce is
where it's at but I've heard of I
haven't used that I've heard of other
stuff if you're not in WordPress land I
think like Magento is like a prepackaged
ecommerce thing so I haven't done
ecommerce in a long time so I'm not sure
what the latest stuff is but if you if
it's a greenfield project meaning like
if you're doing it all from scratch then
I recommend JavaScript
Kellan says I want some of that smoothie
be made I didn't
I have headphones on with music playing
so I didn't hear it but I'm I'm right
below the kitchen I'm in the basement
and my wife was probably making
smoothies so yeah a Friday or the
blender going
I have plans to try to do like a real
office and soundproof it but like right
now until I sell my old house not doing
any major improvements or purchases
that's sold because I'm paying for two
houses right now and it's that's kind of
crazy
so it works but only if I don't spend a
lot of money on other stuff my mom says
have you tried Expo web I haven't tried
the latest release but I did get it
working before it like officially became
then in the last Expo release so I have
tried it but not the latest version I
guess I'm really excited about it I want
to try to update what my project that my
my regular job uses it so I want to try
to update to the latest version of Expo
hopefully sometime this week and and try
that out
okay I'm almost through all the
questions I think and then we'll go back
and and try to get this running locally
lazy newb says I recently made a classic
game using C oh that's really cool
I've I've done very little in C Oh Jason
says how's it going Jesse I said hey to
you at Sur check in between sessions hey
how's it going that's awesome
stir check was a great conference right
like if you've never heard of Star Trek
before and you're able to go to
conferences in the US I definitely
recommend it it's in Columbus Ohio they
hold it at a movie theater so all the
talks are in in the theaters which is I
never thought about it before but a
movie theater is actually a great venue
for a conference it's it's already set
up for people have comfortable seating
there are big screens like it's it's
perfect but it was a great conference
and there we all watched Avengers the
New Avengers after apologies for the for
the yawns okay Yale Brown says is that
the Chrome extension to use github
dark-themed it is yeah so if you notice
my github probably looks different than
the normal github normally github is as
like a white background but I'm using
this github dark theme so using
tampermonkey so tampermonkey is a chrome
plug-in that lets you run javascript on
a website so basically it'll just let
match the URL of the website and say
look when you're at this URL run this
javascript so i'm using a premade script
called github dark
and then I'm pairing that with
tampermonkey to be able to run it and so
every time tampermonkey detects that I'm
on get up it runs the github dark script
and it changes the theme forget oh you
don't have to use pre-made stuff you
could build your own scripts like it'll
it'll work but I prefer dark mode so
that's why my github is dark terrain
says how do I practice front-end I've
learned basics but I need projects with
solutions so I can force my brain to the
actual goal or how the project should
have been made in a better way any
resources mmm I guess well so sorry off
the top of my head I'm not sure so you
need you want like a whole project that
you can work on but then also compared
to that project like solved already know
that there's I think if there is a
resource that does just that I'm not
sure now you could always look at
people's existing projects and then just
try to build them over again right like
look at their site or their app or
whatever and say if I was gonna build
this like how would I do it you build it
and then look at their repo so it after
the open-source project but then you
could look at their repo and see like
you know what did you do differently
what did they do so I mean it could
probably work with anything as long as
it's open source let's see
but almost done few more questions
ioannis says why are you using
javascript and no typescript
I I think typescript is cool I just
haven't taken the time to really learn
it yet also for live streams I kind of
would rather use if I can use like plain
JavaScript so that it's less of a
barrier to entry for people who are
trying to understand the videos but I
have nothing against typescript like I
said I just haven't really taken the
time to use it
for those of you who maybe aren't
familiar with typescript it is like
something that you add on to JavaScript
that makes JavaScript like a strongly
typed language so for instance like in
JavaScript I can declare a variable and
I don't have to say what type that
variable is like it could be anything
and it could change right so it could be
a string a number an array an object
right in in other languages and at least
in some other languages you have to say
what it is so like in c-sharp
i can't just say my variables whatever i
have to say like i have to declare it as
that so I can declare it as an int if I
want an integer and I declare string if
I want to string and then that thing can
only be a string or an integer right it
- you have to declare what type it is
what type of data it is right when you
declare that that variable right so
there are some doing it like that kind
of helps prevent bugs so it does have
its advantages so that that's what
typescript does for JavaScript there are
other advantages at I scripted at the
core that's what typescript does
innocent heart says I know HTML and
Python
what next language you prefer I would
recommend JavaScript right if you know
HTML then JavaScript is a great way to
do more with HTML hug this enough now
let's get into coding
all right the coding is coming let's see
so Rob says you skimped you just get my
question all right I didn't say it we're
just our house question so uh why is
this editor useful decided the question
oh I don't understand exactly what the
question is all right so which which
editor the free code camp one maybe let
me know what you meant by that and I
will definitely answer it all right so
now that we have a fork of this so
basically now that we fork this and me
is like we own this fork of the
repository we can push to it right so
we're not directly making changes to
somebody else's repo right sources
native react react native is a way to
use JavaScript to build mobile apps so
what we're trying to do sar of is make
an in browser editor so you can while
you're in a normal web browser type in
react native code and then see what it
would look like displayed on the screen
okay so we wanted to have the same
behavior as the other free code camp
lessons but with react native
okay all right so I'm going to take a
break from the chat for a little bit and
get back to this so we want to clone
this repo so we go to clone
I have SSH setup so I'm gonna use the
SSH if you don't you can use HTTPS right
and now I'm gonna go to where's my I
guess a good OBS code whoops and it
opened on a different screen new window
so trying to get this over on the right
screen here
that's weird
there we go okay it's not on this screen
so my terminal open and BS code
hopefully make that a little bit bigger
and that'll be easier to read all right
see where we're at
alright I'm gonna wait to apply the
latest updates here
alright documents should have a projects
folder but I guess I don't
so let's make it so I'm gonna do make
directory projects projects cannot
create directory project file exists
where is it I did not miss it or I
didn't see it projects all right see
that's really weird
am I missing that like maybe the list
was just longer and it cut it off anyway
all right now we're in the project
folder you can see I have only one
project in there it's a react native
pop-up menu so now we're gonna do a
clone and we paste in that link that we
just got from github gets close sorry
so now everything that repo is getting
copied over it's a pretty big repo so
this might take a little bit longer than
your your average repository but
shouldn't be too bad
Oh comb sigh guy says it's in the second
column oh I didn't even see this column
over there Wow good good look I was
totally not maybe because these were so
long I didn't even notice this column
good look all right awesome
so now that that's that that's there you
can see we we have free code camp now so
we can go into the free code camp
repository see they have all this stuff
in here
so since we have our package.json we can
install that but let's let's make sure
we're doing it right so let's go to our
whoops I'm not going there we go
let's go to our contributing and take
our steps so we can get started
we do want to run an NPM install and
there we go this what I was looking for
we need to install gulp and Bower
globally all right so let's get that NPM
install running right away - all right
NPM install is gonna take everything
that's in our package JSON file and it's
gonna install at all
okay
and I can probably open another window
here and do the install for the other
ones all right so we're gonna do gulp
and power
in mythology go
great and then now let's do so go p-- is
like a task runner before webpack became
big gulp was kind of the thing to let
you do things like minify your files run
a like a local server like localhost
like run babel concatenate things minify
alright so we should have copán bowers
so globally now we can do a bower
install and get close to everything set
up so let's do ours though oops
no bower dot JSON present hmm is there
supposed to be a bower JSON
no is a Bauer RC totally power
components all right so that looks like
it gets power Jason yeah there should be
about Oh JSON
why don't we have that all right double
check make sure oh you know what I'm not
in the right directory that's why to see
this one open me up in the parent
directory so with CD projects freak okay
there we go now we can run a bower
install
it says Rama mas Ramasamy says video is
not viewable on mobile is anybody else
having trouble on mobile and why is it
not viewable is the far too small I can
I can fix that for sure just let me know
tuturro Dean says hey i subbed awesome
thank you oh and by the way so since the
last time i streamed freakin camps
youtube channel hit 1 million
subscribers which is amazing so thank
you all so much for subscribing and I'm
a subscriber 2 to 3 code camp
I just think that's insane when I
started streaming I think we had like
150,000 so it is the growth has just
been amazing I'm so happy that there's
so many people are using free code camp
and learning how to code okay it looks
like the font is too small on mobile
I could probably bump it up like maybe
one more before it starts to get crazy
oh you know it actually I see my face is
covering this up so I'm not gonna do
anything on this side anymore I'm gonna
do all my commands over here on the left
side so hopefully that little bit bigger
font works as well I'm just afraid if I
go too big then there just won't be
enough on the screen even make sense
alright cool so I think that's
everything installed that we need let's
go back to our contributing file
that was weird
I know how I get all the way back up to
the top okay so private environment is
creating a copy of the sample m and name
it as dot and populate with necessary
API keys and seekers all right so not
all the keys are required to run that
locally that's good because I don't have
any of the keys uh-huh
all right I don't think I'll hopefully I
don't need all these services like
mandrill is for sending emails I doubt I
need that okay when I don't know sending
emails probably need the [ __ ] stuff
okay all right so we need saying let's
check out our environment variables file
oops let's go yeah let's open this up so
since we're in the free code camp
projects folder we could just type in
code and then a period and that opens up
our project like with the folder there
later space like we have word e in there
we have everything if I open up a new
terminal it's gonna be already in that
folder so I like doing it like that I
could it was like tried to navigate
directly through there like through the
UI but I prefer to just do it on the
command line let's do it
well let's view the terminal so we have
our terminal here and see we start out
already in our free code camp project
that's nice because then they don't have
the mistake I made earlier where I tried
to run Bower from the wrong folder okay
so we once there should be an example
environment variable there we go so our
sample M not right now
okay so we have a lot of environment
variables stuff here that I don't think
we'll need made so bloggers so yeah
Trello oh yeah I do not think we will
need any of this stuff hopefully no this
is probably all for the login like log
in with Google log it with github stuff
and then if you do sign up like you get
emails so it's what the owning I think
will really need is this and I'm hoping
that this is this will be default for
when we start this up so let's make a
dot M file for our environment variables
so we can make a new file like this and
just call it dot env and now I'm gonna
paste that and hope that I don't need
the other things just to get this to run
now looks like we need to we need a
command to run this where we get back
here let's see okay so we're gonna start
the [ __ ] server [ __ ] D and then we're
gonna do NPM run only once I'm gonna
copy that and then we'll start it with
go so first things first let's start the
[ __ ] server and it says to start it in
a new terminal so let's create a second
one make this a little bigger I'm gonna
do it here on this side since we
probably won't need to look at it and
that way it doesn't matter if my face is
covering it up my son miss any eyebrows
just walk by a Ambrose I'm doing a live
stream buddy okay he's decided he's
gonna ride his scooter down here okay
[ __ ] Dini I don't know I need [ __ ]
don't I actually let's see I'm just
gonna check the package.json for a
second and see if we have commands that
will help us with
I guess I'm an afterthought [ __ ] all
right that makes sense obviously and he
tends to tell Mogo I should have
expected that I should check out yeah I
don't want that I don't want those keys
there we go okay so you notice I skip by
like the YouTube video and the blog I do
recommend like if you're gonna install a
tool like check out that tools
documentation their official
documentation first if if that doesn't
work or if it's confusing then you can
go to blogs and videos but you're gonna
get the most up-to-date information from
the documentation so check check that
out
come in I wonder if I can install with
chocolaty
chocolatey demos for chocolatey is a
package manager for Windows it's like
homebrew for Mac and it'd be like your
like app get stuff for like Linux choco
and stole MongoDB yeah let's try that
because that's gonna be easier than
going through and install wizard
oh you know what I need to run it from
run administrator
that's my continue let's do command line
from administrator
so so it came up on my other screen but
basically all I'm doing is selecting the
command prompt run as administrator let
me pull this over so now I'm gonna do
Chuck oh I see Oh CHS install MongoDB so
run as administrator on Windows is like
sudo for Mac or Linux yeah I'm not
really reading that stuff probably
should've but I'm just saying yes sure
MongoDB is a what's called a no sequel
database so databases generally fall
into two categories one of two
categories either sequel based SQL write
or no sqr no sequel what's up buddy okay
sorry so my my son my my four year old
just told me that this dog that we're
watching for a couple of weeks and just
ate a diaper so I didn't realize his dog
was eating a diaper right next anyway
it's a pretty good dog though actually
he follows me around everywhere and he's
become my best friend so I like the dog
but this dog does love to eat diapers
and my two-year-old still wears diapers
at night so they're frequently diapers
around
all right
almost ready with this install a Ambrose
the people in the livestream said hi he
says that okay I guess this is almost
done
yay all right cool so hopefully we can
use the command right away
nope we may have to do this in a
different terminal so
let's do this real quick let's shut that
down and oops
let's open this up again and see if we
can sometimes when you install something
new you need to restart it before you
can use any new commands is that the
command no it's not what the heck I
think I missed something let me check
the chat because maybe one of you saw
what I miss
okay I don't think anybody said anything
about it so let me try I'm gonna get
back to the chat in just a minute but I
do want to at least try to run this
alright so start the [ __ ] server they
did say anything about I'll
prerequisites MongoDB I totally missed
that as the prerequisite
hopefully this montgo package wirt
package and we don't have to install
some other way how to run longer DD
I don't want to install it how do I
start MongoDB there we go how do we
start MongoDB from windows yeah okay
enter the command on GoDaddy okay so
[ __ ] D is the command even on Windows
okay
download MongoDB all right let me it
says here they need to create a folder
and then go into that folder which
you've been service referring to been
this is interesting
if then I need to go into where [ __ ]
was installed and run that okay
did I install another terminal program I
thought I installed a terminal for
Windows I guess not
oh okay I don't understand it or you can
have the location in the path
okay comp site guys same where did Chaco
install [ __ ] alright let's let's see if
it program data [ __ ] DB okay so you
thinking maybe if we go into that
directory we can run it from there
okay I have program files in here
program data sorry program data and
where the heck is program data
see program data all right so you need
to go back out then there we go the
program data now we should see [ __ ]
[ __ ] DB what do we have in their data
log no data
GDP whoa okay No
temp chances I guess the binaries are
installed inside C program data
chocolaty okay if you're not familiar at
all with the command CD is that we
traverse directories so change directory
let's see what we have here
[Music]
I don't know where all the chocolatey
stuff is Tony says if you get an error
you have not created a collection go to
Ben and try [ __ ] okay hmm comp size guy
says it's interesting that all of the s
code is a Microsoft product they still
use a batch terminal you can bash as an
option so I've set bash as my default
but I don't think it's the default on
Windows the only only other thing I
could think of is shutting down vs code
completely and reopening I it has
happened to me frequently ya don't say
that when I install something new I
can't use it with vs code until until I
restart battle math nope
we need
okay yeah I definitely can't to thought
here what do we have
try running [ __ ] okay mm-hmm no not
[ __ ] all right let's see I think maybe
now would be a good point to finish
answering the questions and then just
finish up with the show and then I can
try to debug this let's see all right
here's one temp Chan says can you try c
program files MongoDB Server 3.2 been
try that alright let's try that I'm
gonna open another one so I don't
totally lose my place Program Files do
you want to do Program Files or was it
program data
I will go to program data there I'm
sorry Program Files
you have [ __ ] let me get that mom go in
there
all right Andreas is you have to add the
binary file at path system okay so
should be able to do here access tribe
[ __ ] not MongoDB I did trap [ __ ] temp
Chan says because you were using bash I
had okay then I have to try it
did I try [ __ ] is well on here go the
okay yeah de try them on there bash neat
stab [ __ ] Yeti okay
I'm gonna copy that so you have it and
let's check our one level up from system
32 so you may have to use the command
prompt to use MongoDB not the bash I was
gonna see if I can add this to path
now what is it CD oh sorry
LSA that's what I wanted
okay so temp chana same batch don't work
so I do it I have to go back to the
command prompt then
okay
I just wanted to check that how do I
change directories in the command prompt
it's been so long since I've used the
regular command prompt I do not remember
its CD directory why did that not work
for me last time
Oh LS is what didn't work for me sorry
all right I should be able to CD into
Program Files it's been [ __ ] dB and
then what was the next one server 4.0 in
okay
okay it's directory yeah alright cool
that works
alright well we got something now we
guessed something it was an error but it
was something data it's not found
terminating okay cool what's this
welcome to the [ __ ] show all right so
if I just take [ __ ] as it does the
manga show
alright looks like home saga says sent a
link need to create a data folder Doc's
just now run [ __ ] Exe
okay Bhavesh Gupta says I believe it's
done now we can minimize and continue I
guess it's worth a shot right
I mean so it's something is running
right see I think that we wanted to run
was the [ __ ] D and then was supposed to
run this on the port 27 o 17 but the
problem isn't it aired out and I think
because we didn't have any like database
file but I think we we do inside
okay so we need to give it a path the
database path okay
then create data and the bin
I need a date a location for the mungus
server okay all right let me try this
unless I copy and paste in this command
from the chat there we go I like that it
said bye to me okay oops I guess it did
not work when I tried to copy back him
in no it still shut down
Dana Kenobi phone alright maybe I need
to create it first okay so we need to
make the directory first I guess I could
do that from this one it's open so I'm
already on C and I could do make
directory data
TV all right so now we made some
directories let's run this again
dang it data directory easy data not
found why is it not found did we not
just make that directory I am gonna have
to end the stream soon and in work so we
have limited amount of time let's see
that's fair that we did actually just
make this right yes we have data what is
fine president working
oh that's cuz I'm not in the seat I
thought I was already out I guess not
there we go I was hoping I could do them
both but I guess not
alright my mistake let's see if it works
now it works
it worked right Oh a temp Chanin noticed
that I made it in the wrong Directory
sorry I didn't see that that was
definitely the problem okay cool
so this worked cool all right all right
that was pretty sweet we got it working
let's go back here and see what the next
step is oh this is the npm run only once
to see the database actually let's
change the branch while we're here get
check outs react native challenges there
we go come on no package lock Jason I
don't care I don't
just couldn't get rid of it and then now
we'll go there we go
I want to make sure we're on the right
branch before I see this database
because I don't want to miss stuff okay
let me see if there's some more
questions to answer before I got to
finish this stream up I guess I could
run this now no all right something did
not work
wait we don't have that script anymore
I think on this branch a lot more change
than I thought I don't think we even
have that right yeah we don't have that
anymore
dang it alright that was a great time I
think to suck on it but not a bad
session we had a lot of nice
troubleshooting here which
troubleshooting is a big part of being a
developer or an engineer so it may seem
like we didn't do a lot of coding but
what we did do is actually a lot of what
my job is like assess you you have to
figure stuff like this out so I would
say it's realistic in terms of live code
which is why I wanted to do this show
anyway I wanted it to be a realistic
look at at would I do all right I think
I found where I left off apologies if I
end up missing a question here
I will wanted recommendations for
programming glasses because the eyes the
blade hurts hurts his eyes so I do you
have these programming glasses
unfortunately I don't remember I got the
case here
there's 6s ex ey
ex us is the brand that I have here I
like these ones I have another pair at
work I can't remember what brand they
are but they're they're smaller like the
frames or the lenses are smaller so I
actually prefer these because the big
lenses seem to block out more light but
I think that's not really a brand thing
that's more of just a style so I
recommend getting a lens and frame style
that has like big lenses to block out
more I do like these at home it's not as
big of a deal because I can control the
lighting better but at work there's such
a glare on the screen and so many like
fluorescent lights that I do get a
headache if I don't wear my blue light
blocking glasses
I'm gonna skip some of the comments
sorry for not reading out all the
comments but I just have to get to work
so I'm gonna try to just get to the
questions see your axes where can I
learn in code campout org go to free
code camp dot org and check out the
curriculum and that's where all the
lessons are like someone has an in
pronounceable name so this is a
wondering if you could help me give me
some idea to start a project as web dev
I'm stuck on learning there's there's so
many different things you can do to
start a project it's it's hard to say
there are websites that have lists of
like potential projects you could do so
I would try searching for those websites
and then you'll get a ton of good ideas
for projects I don't know what the URLs
are for those sites of thought in my
head unfortunately but it shouldn't be
too hard to find on on laga collins i'm
really sorry i mispronounced your name
let me know how I am [ __ ] pronounced it
says is there a terminal plugin for
sublime I don't really know because I've
never used sublime any sublime users out
there know of a terminal plugin
Joshua wolf s what languages react
native in or is that the framework yet
react native is a framework but the
language is JavaScript
jackass if this was the baby math games
though no we're taking a break from that
to work on something for the free code
camp curriculum but we're gonna come
back to that and fortunately there's
been the part of the reason why I felt
kind of stuck with the baby math game
was I wanted to use expo to run it on a
mobile device but expo didn't support
react hooks yet but the latest version
of Expo does so we should be able to use
Expo
to run and test it on mobile emulators
and to create builds for mobile devices
so I'm excited about that and we will
get back to that and I'm gonna try to
have my oldest son who's nine years old
I'm gonna try to set him up with some
sort of like I don't know online drawing
tool or something to maybe make some
some characters and artwork for the game
so that might be cool see what he comes
up with we got a question about react
native versus flutter who will win I
have no idea who will win really it's
hard to say I mean react native is
already eight has been out there longer
so I guess it already has a bigger user
base sorry but honestly I haven't
actually tried out flutter yet so I
don't think I could give a really good
answer to that question
Josh wolf says can you really use this
to make Android apps you can definitely
use react native to make Android apps
I'm skipping there's a lot of stuff that
was in relation to what we were trying
to install here which seems like this
kind of stalled out I have to figure
that out later
almost to the end of the chat here
Rustom says which computer can you offer
for programming but not iMac so gets
recommendations yeah I mean I'm accent
pretty expensive if if you can find a
good deal on a MacBook Pro I think
that's I really like those like for
intern if you want a laptop
I recommend the MacBook Pro if you want
a desktop though yeah I I personally
think that you will get more power for
your money if you go with a Windows
computer and try to get basically get
your custom build for what you want
like I switch to Windows desktop for
live streaming because my MacBook Pro
could not handle it
and it ended up being way cheaper to get
what I needed with a PC than it was for
a Mac in particular I needed a powerful
processor with as many cores as possible
because from what I read that would help
the most with streaming and to be to get
that in a Mac would be very expensive so
I think if you figure out what you want
your computer to do do the research to
see what components you need that it
will help the most you're way more
likely to find a good deal and exactly
what you want with a PC but in terms of
laptops you can't beat the Mac trackpads
they're just really nice I've never seen
one anything come close to that on a
Chromebook or on Windows laptop if it's
too expensive though to get the Mac I
would honestly I would look into getting
a Chromebook in running a cloud editor
because they're way less expensive very
reliable startup is super fast like
faster than anything I've ever seen
so I think that's probably the route I
would go like if I was gonna buy a new
laptop and not go with a Mac
I lost my place I'm sorry
which coding language do you use I use
JavaScript mostly so I think JavaScript
is definitely good good language to use
[Music]
you have a question if if react is
JavaScript why does it need installed
it's a JavaScript library so you need to
install it just like any NPM package
would need installed comp Sakai says do
you use Expo at work I do i do use Expo
Expo is a tool or a set of tools that
work well with react native if you're
using react native I definitely
recommend checking out Expo it makes
some things like like running your in
testing locally and bundling a lot
easier and it has a lot of cool built-in
like modules it's it's definitely useful
and marketing wants to know what
language to use to build a facebook like
website I if it were me I'd use
JavaScript because that's what I'm best
with right but you could probably build
something similar with almost anything
it doesn't seem to make sense to use
like react since react is a Facebook
thing that's it kind of seems fitting if
you're trying to build a Facebook clone
so we'll ask is react native just a
front end or could it have like all
logic for example a game built out of
JavaScript yeah actually react native
could have all the logic for a game if
you wanted like persistent storage or
something you know you'd have to link it
up to a database but I mean yeah you
could definitely build a game then just
use react native let's see I keep losing
my place I this scroll the scroll with
my mouse is a little bit rough here you
know let me see if I can pop this chat
window out and get a little bit nicer
experience here
compsat guy says I was told Expo isn't
ideal for prod you know what we're not
in fraud yet at work so I'm not I'm not
sure about that right now we don't have
any like short-term plans to take the
mobile version in the prod so I don't
really have to deal with that yet when I
get closer to that then I'll have to
decide whether or not I want to stick
with Expo for doing the prod bundle or
just use regular react native but I'll
keep that in mind I haven't heard
anything one way or another the creative
girl says hi I am starting to learn
JavaScript do I need to start with
another JavaScript what do you think
about jQuery any JavaScript books to
recommend which framework is best thank
you it's a lot of questions one yes
start with vanilla JavaScript that's
always good to know jQuery is is not bad
to learn there are a lot of jobs where
you need to use jQuery because a lot of
sites are built on it if you want to
build brand new sites though I would
recommend not going with jQuery and
maybe trying to do vanilla JavaScript or
maybe a framework which brings me to the
framework question I personally like
react but there are other frameworks out
there that are used for a lot of things
so angular and view seem to be pretty
popular as well but certainly that's up
to you they all have their strengths and
weaknesses any JavaScript books check
out the series code you don't no js' I
believe you can read them for free I
think they're all up on github and then
there's also a book called eloquent
JavaScript and there is an online
version of that available for free as
well those are definitely great places
to start if you're learning JavaScript
viii web code says do you have a car if
so what's the name I Drive a 2017 Honda
Civic when I have all the kids and
everything I have a Honda Pilot it's a
2009 Honda Pilot but the car I normally
drive to work is Honda Civic well I want
to get a Tesla one day because they're
just really cool but they're expensive
so that's not gonna happen anytime soon
[Music]
viii web code says tell me five ways to
make money from coding five ways I don't
know okay and you just you get a job
build websites so your websites like I
don't know anybody with that Charlie
swagger says hey Jesse Windows and Linux
have a big issue in react native iOS
development and no one uses expo in
industry okay that's interesting take
obviously keep that in mind for expo I
do know that there are issues with iOS
development
I usually develop on a Mac so it's not
really an issue for me obviously like
when I'm streaming I'm using a PC so
that's gonna limit us if to do things
like that we'll have to stick with
Android but you know the in terms of my
job I have a Mac so that's not gonna be
an issue for that
the comp site guide mentions there is a
sink storage and react native that's
true we're talking about building a game
with react native and I mentioned
database assume that's what you're
talking about
yes so you could do a sink storage I was
thinking more like in terms of
persistent data like if you wanted the
user to be able to like let's say change
phones and still get access to their
data then you'd need some sort of
database but yeah if you just want the
data stored locally to persist you can
definitely use a sink storage which
basically behaves very similarly to what
local storage does in a browser
sure-sure Rangi sony says hey Jesse I'm
almost completed with reactant now what
are the steps like Redux what are the
next steps like Redux component API flux
I don't know these if you're almost
finished with react I'd say the next
step is build stuff with react if you
find that you need help with state
management check out Redux
or like context API or something my
thing if you know react just start
building as you find you need something
else then learn that other thing but you
can build a lot of cool stuff with just
react so that's where I would personally
would go next and marketing says which
language is basic to coding I mean I I
don't really know exactly what you mean
by that
but you can do pretty much anything in
most of the main languages now I don't
know if there is one that is like the
basic coding language
Bullock says can you start learning
right directly skipping vanilla
JavaScript I you should definitely know
some JavaScript first before you learn
react I mean you don't have to be a
JavaScript master but react uses a lot
of JavaScript so you're gonna have to
learn JavaScript to use react anyway
Rustom Zee says what can you tell about
gaming laptops should I buy they're for
programming I've thought about getting
like gaming PCs and laptops for
programming before I think they would
work but I kind of think you would be
spending more money than you need to so
if you have the money great but if you
don't really want to do a lot of gaming
and you just want to do programming I
think like the gaming setups would have
way more graphics capabilities then you
would need so you probably could get
something less expensive and it may be
as good or better for programming
if you web code says what do you think
about angular and view are they dead oh
no I don't think they're dead I think
it's just they're just different I think
angular is used by a lot of big
companies view seems to have I don't see
view being used as much in big companies
I don't obviously don't know about all
the companies here but and I like I
haven't used view and I haven't used the
newer versions of angular so this is
just kind of an outsider perspective but
I still see a lot of jobs for angular
developers some jobs for view but I
don't think either one is dead Javy Whip
says can I buy a Tesla car with a
JavaScript coding job I mean maybe it
depends like I really can't yes so I
have four kids so I have a coding job
but I can't with four kids I can't
afford a Tesla if I decided to like
really save up and
not spend my money on anything else for
a while then maybe I could buy one but
it's it's not an easily affordable
option for me but if I was single I
could probably buy a Tesla and be fine
not like the Roadster but you know like
the cheapest version of the Tesla
alright cool so I've gotten through all
if not most of the questions reversed
that most if not all of the questions
and I gotta get started with my my
normal job now thank you all so much for
watching I'm gonna really try my best to
start doing live streams regularly again
I know I got away from it for a while
sorry about that
bother me on Twitter and Instagram and
stuff if I don't stream ask me what I'm
doing and why I'm not streaming and
that'll help me to get back into it if
you like the streams if you don't then
just you know forget about it and maybe
I'll go away okay I think that's all I
need to do maybe a little bit of
debugging maybe I'll save that for the
stream maybe I'll do it outside the
stream we'll see but thank y'all so much
for your help
it was definitely useful to get all this
stuff working and I'll be back again I'd
be really gonna do at least one more
stream this week if I can I do have more
conferences and a vacation coming up so
I'm gonna have some more breaks coming
up but hopefully not as long as this
last break was so until next time thank
you all so much and have a great day